I'm interested in asking M uh ma Max
this question because of your extensive
coverage of it your views on on the
conflict yeah and uh right now I think
it's fair to say every single person
wants peace there's clearly a divide
though and it's that Israel's view of
peace is very different from Palestinian
view of peace and then say our view of
peace right middle of the road anti-war
Americans who are like why are we
involved in this and how do we make it
stop or do we do nothing at all and stay
completely out of it because like what
is what is this
[Music]
what what what how do we if if you know
if if Hamas is like we're going to go
take civilians because they're
bargaining chips for us you've now got a
story where I'm like bro I'm 37 this
conflict's been going on a lot longer
than I've been alive and all I know is I
watch a video of people storming a music
festival killing and kidnapping people
all I see that's bad we want to stop I
see three ways for this to end either
it's the total obliteration and
annihilation of 2 million Palestinians
or it's they Refugee and they flee the
land and they come here to the United
States are somewhere else or they are
absorbed into another Nation I I those
are three solutions that Israeli
leadership is kind of putting forward
because they cannot exist with
Palestinians in their midst and like
Egypt doesn't want to take them and and
Jordan was doesn't want to take them and
Lebanon doesn't want no one wants to
take pal why won't Egypt open up Rafa
and let them come because it's
politically useful to have the
Palestinian problem the F the fight with
between the the Arabs and the Jews
that's politically useful to Jordan it's
politically useful to Lebanon it's
politically useful to Egypt it's for the
same reason that many Americans don't
want Hondurans or Mexicans coming across
the border the Egyptians look down on
Palestinians and they consider them a
burden on a society with 90 million
people with a very weak State uh where
there's a lot of poverty um and Rafa the
Rafa Crossing between Gaza and Israel
was bombed today uh with many people who
are dual Nationals trying to get out as
Netanyahu and the is isi leadership are
saying leave Gaza and we won't bomb you
but they have nowhere to go um but you
know on this issue of the solution I
mean we're entering a very dangerous
phase and we're looking at the Holy Land
right now so this does affect us all if
this conflict moves from a political
conflict which it always has been it's
not about the Bible it's about the
colonization of the land of Palestine
and people trying to get their land and
rights back and and and then another
group of people trying to have a state
run along ethn religious lines as a
Jewish state if it moves into a
religious conflict we're all screwed and
it's going there this operation waged by
Hamas and um Palestinian Islamic Jihad
was called alaxa flood it's about the
alaxa mosque and what's been going on
there is that the security minister of
Israel who's the biggest Fanatic in
Israeli Society his name is idar benir
he's LED literal riots against
Palestinian sh he's so extreme the
Israeli military would not allow him in
he's been convicted in Israeli courts of
terrorism he is now the security
minister because Benjamin Netanyahu
needs him and his small party in order
to maintain his Coalition he has been
leading groups up to the aloa compound
of uh Jewish extremists who try to break
in there into the third holiest site in
Islam in a direct provocation and what
they want to do is blow up the aloa
compound and bring back the third Jewish
temple and they belong to a movement
called the temple movement which sees
the Jewish prayer that takes place at
the Western Wall as phony as fake what
they think the original prayer that took
place there was the mass slaughtering of
sheep continuously and they want to do
that there so this is these are kind of
elements that are provoking one another
and leading us into a religious conflict
that would be disastrous we were talk
real quick doesn't Al in Arabic mean the
yeah kind of yeah I just wanted to point
that out because it's funny because we
say the Al Whatever like we say the the
I know I just thought it was interesting
we were talking I I I disagree about the
context the modern context being the
actual driver and we were talking
earlier today uh before the show about
the the actual driver I it is biblical
it goes all the way back to to Genesis
the between the feud between Ishmael and
Isaac or the the the the fact that the
story says that Isaac was God's CH was
was chosen by God and Ishmael is the
father of the Arabs Isaac's the father
of the Jews this is this this is like
the Hatfield and McCoy Feud on steroids
it goes back thousands and thousands and
thousand 3,000 years or whatever I don't
know how far back but people that put it
into a modern context I understand that
like because there are things that
inflame the tensions but the tensions go
far beyond just you know it it's it's
deeper than Islam and that's the thing
that most Americans don't realize
Americans think that it's about a
religion and it's not it's an ethnic
Feud that goes far deeper than than a
religion I think a lot of the tension
comes from that but the violence is
coming from the
colonization uh sure it's it's you can
always do a video chat and get past your
hatred of each other but if you're if
you're going to die you have no choice
some people can I don't I I know this
this is particularly contentious so yes
ladies and gentlemen we we I I I do want
to bring on I'd love to bring on someone
who a journalist who has covered the
Israeli perspective not that I think
that you necessarily don't but you do
have your biases I wrote a book about
the Israeli perspective it's called
Goliath and I lived in Jerusalem in one
of the most Jewish areas for almost a
year just trying to absorb that that's
fair but I'm je and I'm Jewish myself
and I came to this understanding by
first going on the birthright Israel
trip which is a free trip for Jews uh it
was then 18 to 25 and you know it's
basically like the best sex vacation
ever uh like they want you to mate they
want Jews to have relationships because
you know we're not get you know we don't
pratie so they're encouraging you to
have sex with Israeli soldiers it's a
big party but I got really really into
the situation there and it was right at
the dawn of the second in tiata and it
affected me in a way that they didn't
want it to I mean they did propagandize
us so for there there are obviously a
lot of people who we got some chats
where they're saying it's great you're a
real journalist covering this cuz the
you know but then there are other people
saying that you're you're a joke and
you're wrong about this stuff but I do
want to point out the the the seemingly
contradictory uh statement you made
earlier I I say seemingly in that the
people's view of tribal politics uh you
you had praised for Donald Trump's uh
peace efforts before the show I don't
know if you want to depending on which
piece effort talking for sure but we're
talking about North Korea and South
Korea and you were saying like you know
I won't speak for you in the Bloods yeah
yeah yeah I mean a one point to you real
quick before I get into that um if
Christians should be paying special
attention to this conflict because the
Christians who live in Bethlehem they
have nothing to do with Hamas they're
not represented by any of these factions
but they are affected by occupation and
they are being forced out of their lands
where they are carrying the tradition of
the disciples uh the Anastos family who
I know had a the wall the separation
wall built entirely around their home
and shop and that was the end of their
existence there they are directly
descended from the disciples so this
isn't just about Jews and Muslims and by
the way Jews and Muslims resisted the
Crusaders in Jerusalem we haven't always
been enemies but to your point about
Trump uh no you wanted to say something
well just the the I wanted to point out
that the the way you've characterized
this you've you've called you've you've
called Jews terrorists multiple times
and every time that anyone taught that I
talk about the the fact that the
operation was a terror operation you
push back on it so I I understand that
you have a a perspective and it's
totally cool I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to to say you're wrong for having
an opinion or having having a
perspective but I do want to point out
you you are characterizing the Israelis
as Jews and you talk about how farri
right and and how bloodthirsty they are
and the terror attack you you've been
pushing back on and saying well it's not
a terror attack and that Etc so I mean I
just wanted to call attention to it it
it is not just that Jews are terrorists
or that the uh Palestinians are
terrorists this particular issue this
particular flare up or whatever is
because of a terrorist attack but it's
not that one side or the other are the
bad guys and the good guys I at least I
don't see it that way it's well it's for
me it's about Justice and Injustice one
side is much more powerful than the
other and is has been abusing them
historically but Israel to me does not
represent Judaism to me that's an not
that's an anti-semitic point of view and
actually anti-semites try to implicate
all Jews by invoking Israel's crimes I
see Israel as embracing the philosophy
of Zionism and if you go to Brooklyn and
you see all those Ultra Orthodox Jews
from the satmar clan they're not
zionists in many ways they're
anti-zionist so all Jews are not
zionists back to Trump the I yes I I
mean as we were saying before the show I
mean I stood and cheered when he crossed
the DMV DMZ into North Korea I never
thought I would see an American
president do that and in some and so in
so many ways um Trump going off script
was the greatest thing about the Trump
era I never thought American president
would do that admitting the weapons
deals of Saudi Arabia and all that stuff
the oil fields in Syria it's it was it's
like not good things but it's like he's
saying it yeah even with the bad things
he lifted the mask on American Empire
because he wasn't trying to be elegant
about it he just told the truth about
what we are uh with with with Israel
though I don't know if you remember but
it was like in 2015 he went to the
Republican Jewish Coalition and he said
like I'm a landlord a lot of you you
guys are landlords we need to make a
deal with Israel Palestine and the they
called him an anti-semite for saying
that he's like he's calling Jews
landlords who are
dealmakers and then he changed and Jared
Kushner came in the equation his
son-in-law thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net out and we'll see you all
next
time